el domingo en la noche el presidente
afgano cyril ramaphosa se pronunció con
respecto a la nueva variante del
coronavirus identificado en sudáfrica
llamada omicron así como con respecto a
las restricciones que muchos países han
puesto con respecto al tráfico aéreo de
sudáfrica el presidente de macosa fue
muy enfático en criticar a estos países
que de manera muy apresurada empezaron a
bloquear el tráfico de áridos de
sudáfrica afectando su industria
turística y por supuesto una de las las
columnas de su economía sobre todo en
esta época de verano en el hemisferio
sur
ramaphosa declaró estas medidas de
apresuradas discriminatorias e
injustificadas y que carecen de
fundamento científico
ramaphosa también recordó que en la
declaración de roma del g20 las naciones
acordaron que se apoyarían mutuamente
para restablecer el sector turístico
después de casi dos años de pandemia y
estaba totalmente en contra de las
medidas que se están imponiendo contra
sudáfrica en este momento rama pasa
también recordó que en este momento en
europa en varios países han identificado
ya varios casos de esta nueva variante
llamada omicron y que ninguna de estas
naciones europeas están bloqueando su
tráfico aéreo por lo que declaró contra
sudáfrica una medida discriminatoria y
rama posa cerró su alocución con dos
llamados uno a la comunidad
internacional para que de manera urgente
cancele estas medidas y estas
restricciones contra sudáfrica y un
segundo llamado a la ciudadanía
sudafricana para que acuda cuanto antes
a los puestos de salud para completar
sus pautas de vacunación y así evitar la
posibilidad de reducir la posibilidad de
que se produzcan nuevas variantes y de
que se dispare exponencialmente el
número de infecciones